what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i am your host
warren thompson and today we're talking
about something very very exciting and
important mutants in the mcu now the
official trailer for doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness showed us that
the illuminati is going to be introduced
in the film and the mutants or x-men are
going to be introduced as well now x-men
in the mcu is something that we've
wanted for an insanely long time but
there is a big theory a very very
important theory that you need to know
that states that the mutants could
already be in the mcu and i know a lot
of theories out there have been talking
about this lately however this is the
original theory that i think makes the
most sense and it's coming from my buddy
greg alba over at the real rejects now i
really really like this theory because
it kind of plays off of the house of m
storyline but it switches it up because
we know that marvel studios never really
goes word for word story for story of
what the comics actually do they switch
it up a little bit so this i actually
think could be the most accurate theory
out there now greg hasn't really gotten
credit for this theory and he really
should because it's a really great
theory he took a lot of time putting the
effort into coming up with this theory
and connecting all of the dots so today
i'm gonna switch it up he usually reacts
to me i'm gonna react to him and we're
gonna talk about his theory because it's
really really good so if you haven't
already made your way to his channel
checked out the theory do that now go
ahead and like the video come back here
and let's talk about what exactly this
means so greg posted this theory two
weeks ago february 6th let's take a look
at what it says
cu timeline we've been watching for the
last 13 years
no more mutants has already happened
like i said i know this sounds like a
bit of a reach however i think this
would answer some questions we've had
about the mcu questions specifically
regarding the events of wanda vision i
think it would better help reintroduce
x-men and mutants into the marvel
cinematic universe and with this phase
after wanda vision loki the even the
trailer for moon knight this is called
multiverse of madness this is the
mind-bending phase of the mcu what more
of a mind-bender would it be than to
reveal to us that mutants were already
there and that the actions of the
scarlet witch erasing the existence of
mutants
already
dive into this with me spider-man no way
hopefully that's yours that's possible
to erase people from the world's memory
including doctor strange via forgetting
who peter parker was spoilers for
spider-man no way what if this movie
takes it the next step further since one
division was announced everyone has been
looking to the house of m comic books
like the go-to source material to better
understand and perhaps predict what
might happen in the marvel cinematic
universe now that's an important comic
but the comic that i'd recommend looking
into is actually one of the follow-ups
the house of m x-men endangered species
in that comic after the existence of
mutants has already been reduced from
millions to only hundreds around the
world hank mccoy aka beast sets out on a
journey to find a way to reverse the
spell wanda cast and along this journey
he eventually meets up with dr strange
who tells him exactly this what she did
completely changed reality that it's
nearly impossible to see where reality
ends and her alteration of it begins she
cast her spell over billions of souls
over worlds and dimensions reality has
been consumed by her spell the magic is
woven through everything welded to all
there is so in the source material
itself dr strange declares her spell
affected worlds and dimensions i.e the
multiverse i tried rhyming that didn't
quite work so the main rumor ever since
this movie was announced at comic con is
that wanda maximoff will be the main
villain of this movie and another rumor
that's been circulating is that the
illuminati might be featured in this
movie and they would essentially act as
protectors of the multiverse multiversal
threats with this being a doctor strange
movie with the few appearances that we
got of scarlet witch in a movie about
traveling the multiverse why would wanda
maximoff be considered the ultimate
threat to the multiverse is it because
the illuminati believe in witchcraft
lore i don't think so maybe this is the
real reason why agatha harkness who once
possessed the darkhold which grants
access to the multiverse told wanda
you're supposed to be a myth so am i
saying that we're in some repeated time
loop where the wanda we've been with the
whole time has already done this no i'm
not saying that loki has already
introduced us to variants so as we saw
in the setup of that show a variant of
our protagonist was considered a
multiversal threat right
and this is the biggest part right here
okay
so i'm not going to show you greg's
entire video because i want you to go
watch it because i feel that he really
deserves to get the credit for this so i
will link it down below in the
description and the pin comment go watch
this video by greg over at the new
rockstars but here's the very important
part that he talks about and he did this
video before the second trailer for
multiverse of madness the first official
full trailer came out now when it came
out it actually really proves this
theory pretty accurate he talks about
the illuminati coming in and being kind
of the protectors of the multiverse
which is what i've always talked about
for you know over a year now i think now
the illuminati comes in and this is
where things get really really intense
and really important now we hear who we
presume is patrick stewart's professor
xavier say we should tell him the truth
now we also see
to greg's point here variants we see a
wanda or scarlet witch variant now these
are two really really important things
and i believe that they connect to each
other doctor strange goes in front of
the council of the illuminati and
patrick stewart's professor x says we
should tell them the truth what is the
truth right now a lot of people are kind
of linking this to the scarlet witch
right now but what greg does is he links
it to the fact that the scarlet witch
could have already said no more mutants
in a different universe now as greg
pointed out
this means that it could be affected
across the entire multiverse and not
just in one
universe the comics kind of made that
clear that they don't really know the
extent of it but it really affects
everything and it's probably going to be
the same way in the mcu now here's the
twist and it's a really good point to
greg's point here it's probably not r
wanda who said no more mutants because
how could she really know about mutants
she didn't really know that she was the
scarlet witch but we see a different
variant and this variant looks
pretty dang intense in the trailers so
the theory here is that this variant
said no more mutants and that's what the
truth is that professor xavier is
referring to and now the biggest threat
to the entire universe is this variant
of the scarlet witch and now our scarlet
witch because we can assume this variant
is kind of getting in her mind and kind
of controlling her a little bit making
her a little bit more evil but if you
think about this theory it makes a lot
of sense because as greg goes on to talk
about there would have to be a lot of
things kind of retconned into the mcu if
we wanted to bring the mutants in at
this point which wouldn't really work
because the mutants have been around
since pretty much the creation of humans
in the comics the celestials created and
we just kind of saw this in the eternals
but they created the eternals and the
deviants but mutants also came out of
this in the comics now they didn't
mention that in the eternals but it
could be because the existence of
mutants have been erased because we
can't have mutants be a part of the very
beginning of time and just say hey
they've been there the whole entire time
but we haven't talked about them that
doesn't really make sense because
especially if you take to the comics
there's a lot of stuff that's against
the mutants there's kind of a racism
against mutants people hate mutants
right now you can't just ignore all of
that but
we can have people remember that mutants
have been around the whole entire time
and they don't actually like mutants and
that would kind of solve the problem of
bringing the mutants in right now so to
me this theory actually makes a lot of
sense wanda does say no more mutants but
it's not rwanda and it happened in
another universe now i still think our
universe is the main mcu timeline i've
heard some other theories that state
like well maybe we're living in a pocket
universe no i don't think that's true i
just think that we're exploring the
multiverse in this very specific movie i
think we can discover that multiverses
and universes are affecting other
different universes now that's what this
movie really is all about now greg does
bring up an excellent point not too long
ago kevin feige released a scene that
was never released before a post-credit
scene for iron man 1 where nick fury
mentions mutants now kevin feige does
everything with full purpose and he
knows exactly what he's doing and he
plans things like super far in advance
so he absolutely did this because the
mutants were coming now when you release
this the fox deal had already been done
they have the rights to the mutants at
this point so they have planned for the
mutants to come which further proves
that
things are about to get pretty serious
in multiverse madness they are going to
bring in some mutants that are existing
in other universes and hopefully this
will actually start to introduce our
mutants and our universe to the mcu
perhaps they were there the entire time
and i kind of think that they were and i
kind of think that after this movie is
done perhaps we'll get a reversal of
this spell and mutants will now exist in
our universe but what do you think do
you like this theory i personally do
don't forget to go over to the real
rejects and check out this video give it
a like and give them a subscription if
you have not yet and of course don't
forget to like my video and subscribe so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
marvel news for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof